[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de retour à port marly pour une nouvelle
émission concernant cette université des
mairies donc à suivre en direct sur tv
78 depuis ce matin de nouveaux invités
nous ont rejoints fibres et au bonjour
bonjour mr du chéné rocancourt et
vincent millions pour jour à vous alors
vous êtes conseiller municipal délégué à
la mise en oeuvre des chartes de la
commune nouvelle de saint germain en
laye et de fourqueux notamment nous
allons parler vous l'avez compris de
fusion de rapprochement à des communes
est-ce que c'était aujourd'hui une
solution inévitable philippe brillault
revenu sur votre choix tout d'abord
pourquoi avoir décidé de rapprocher le
chesnay d'euros concours maintenant que
cette fusion est effective depuis
quelques mois vous avez employé un mot
inévitable est ce que le mariage est
inévitable la réponse est non est ce que
le mariage peut être souhaité qu'en 7 à
2 oui donc la fusion
c'est une confiance entre deux communes
représentées par deux mers c'est avant
tout la confiance confiance entre les
élus les deux maires et confiance entre
les élus et la population
c'est le socle de la réussite de la
fusion pour le plan fiscal aussi c'est
important pour elle alors plus de
ressources pour permettre à ses de nos
pays va apprécier les motivations parce
que vous avez toujours quelque part
et c'est là où faut se méfier comme dans
le mariage moi j'aime bien la
comparaison
faut-il un dominant et un dominé sa
marche jamais très longtemps
ou alors c'est pas forcément vraiment
bien vécu ça veut dire qu'il faut avoir
en plus de la confiance de respect c'est
à dire que quand vous êtes une commune
la plus importante qui peut représenter
quelques fois dix fois la commune avec
lequel on s'associe il faut respecter
les deux c'est à dire qu'il ya pas de
taille
on se respecte indépendamment de son
nombre d'habitants de ses finances ou re
est bien évidemment la petite commune
qui va adhérer à la fusion elle le fait
principalement par obligation parce
qu'elle va pu arriver à faire son budget
parce qu'elles n'arrivent plus à donner
tout ce que les habitants attendent
d'eux
donc en fait il y a un besoin de la
petite commune et puis pour la commune
la plus importante
il ya des intérêts effectivement et donc
c'est le croisement de ces attentes
réciproques matériel administrative
historiques ou autre qui fait qu' on
peut réussir
sous ces deux conditions confiance et
respect comment vous l'avez vécu du côté
de defour que avec ce rapprochement avec
saint germain en laye le premier conseil
s'est tenue au pareil en janvier 2019
fait c'est une procédure plus longue
alors initialement n'était pas deux
volets t4 puisque faut quand même le
rappeler le principe de la commune
nouvelle c'est la liberté donc on est
parti sur un projet à quatre communes
une commune sentent comme l'expliqué
philippe brillault commune appelée
d'importantes dix fois plus nombreuses
que les trois autres communes qui
faisait à peu près 3500 4000 habitants
s'est également fait 42 mille donc le
projet était à 4 on a fait une étude qui
a duré presque un an où on a étudié à la
fois le projet à 4 mais aussi le projet
à 3 parce que initialement l'idée la
commune nouvelle sur saint germain
s'était pas 5 la main c'était marie
marly fort que l'est dans la ville
et puis sont dits en effet comme dit
philippe on peut rien faire sur la
commune centre
on a besoin de la puissance de la
commune centre donc on a fait une étude
avec les quatre communes et une étude
avec les trois communes et tous les
curseurs montrer qu'à 4 c'était corpiq
mieux qu'à 3 parce que saint germain a
mené un certain nombre de puissances
d'équipement donc on est parti sur un
projet à 4 et puis pour les raisons qui
sont la liberté de chacun les communes
de marie mariée elle étend la ville
n'ont pas suivi le mouvement et on s'est
retrouvé à fusionner à deux avec
fourqueux en effet dans un rapport de 1
à 10 et en gros on dirait c'est un peu
plus compliqué que
pour que parce qu'il pensait partir avec
trois autres petites communes et
rejoindre une grosse et là il était le
petit poucet face à saint germain mais
sont rendus compte que de toute façon
ils s'étaient leur avantage et dire fort
que comme disait philippe un moment ils
peuvent plus faire des certain nombre de
choses dans les ive et même sont allées
partement riche dans une région riche on
a des problématiques de ce budget pour
toutes les communes et donc un moment il
faut mutualiser faut trouver des
solutions et la commune nouvelle sur le
fait de la liberté c'est comme le
mariage c'est un livre un mariage
librement consentis n'ont pas un mariage
forcé comme c'est dingue et ans avec les
lois de l'intercommunalité est bon on
choisit son partenaire et quand on est
sur ton partenaire on part avec lui pour
une longue route un long mariage et on
est parti pour la première année selon
marier avec fort que ça se passe pour
l'instant très bien quelquefois il ya
des contrats de mariage aussi alors
justement est ce que tout ça est borné
comment concrètement ça se met en place
il ya des bornes ya des limites il ya
des lundis charte notamment que vous
veillez à mettre en voyage bien sûr il
ya des chartes mais il est aussi très
grande liberté
d'abord sur le périmètre avec qui on se
marie et en effet sur les chartes on met
un petit peu ce qu'on veut dans les
chartes nous on a fait trois chars
qu'une chaire de service public où
justement l'idée était de maintenir et
augmenter le service public pour les
habitants on avait une charte sur
l'environnement une charte de
gouvernance mais ça c'est pas forcément
obligatoire via la loi pélissard la loi
2010 puisque complétée par la loi
publicitaire et la loi gatel maintenant
qu'ils sont les bornes administratives
et législatives
après les élus dans ce cadre là ils font
un petit peu à leur saucisson libre il
n'y a pas le choix de compétences
obligatoires comme dans l'intercours en
fait ils prennent l'ensemble de la
compétence de la commune ils font une
commune nouvelle qui est pas une strate
supplémentaire qui est une vraiment une
commune pleine et entière
donc nous on est a commencé depuis le
bas le 1er janvier 2019 et on est vers
la la fin de notre première année
d'existence ensemble on va commencer à
tirer les premiers bilans
on a bien avancé sur sambre de choses
dit encore beaucoup de choses à faire et
l'équipe municipale qui va être élu en
2020 va continuer sur le programme de la
commune nouvelle
à partir de ce que l'on ait fait les
chartes ont dit c'est à dire un certain
nombre de projets de maintenir les
services publics de proximité maintenir
une mairie délégués sur la commune
délégué de fourqueux un certain nombre
de choses qui sont écrit que la commune
doit faire vite
aujourd'hui avec cette fusion on a les
avantages de l'intercommunalité sans les
inconvénients c'est ça le principe je
voudrais quand même signaler que saint
germé ils sont quand même gourmands ils
font un mariage à quatre nouveaux
chalets on est resté à dourgne rester
classique vous vous dites que vous êtes
très libre mais à vouloir être quatre
vous avez donc on va pas parler un peu
de ce qui s'est passé pas je crois ce
qui est important c'est de savoir qui
prend la décision
est-ce qu'il faut passer par un
référendum avec la population ou est ce
que ce sont les maires qui ensemble je
dirais sont capables de présenter aux
deux conseils
la délibération moi je pense que si les
maires ont conscience que la population
l'attend il faut passer directement par
les conseils si on si ce n'est pas
forcément contractualiser ou forcément
évident il faut passer la parole à la
population je ferme cette parenthèse
ensuite y'a un état des lieux financiers
des deux communes qui est fondamentale
puisque chacun mène sa dot voilà il est
évident qu'une petite commune va se
retrouver avec une grosse cote
et pourquoi par exemple chez nero
concours se sont mariés ensemble parce
que le chesnay compense une ville jeune
vieillit c'est écoeurant concours qui
paraissait une ville plutôt âgés étaient
en train de se rajeunir
donc ça veut dire que quelque part
l'association des 2 permettaient de
maintenir une démographie un turnover
compatible avec une ville qui doit
éviter de vieillir au niveau fiscal on
avait des fiscalités différentes dont on
a essayé quelque part de les conserver
pour chacun de façon à ce que les
avantages acquis soit fait le personnel
aussi parce que le personnel a toujours
peur que comme ya un volant bas on peut
pas en mettre 2 il ya deux mers quel est
celui qui va passer le manche à l'autre
donc il faut se mettre d'accord sinon ça
peut pas aller et et vice versa pour
chaque adjoint
il ya un adjoint aux affaires scolaires
peut pas y en avoir deux donc toute
cette alchimie politique il faut la
faire
donc ça veut dire que les habitants
doivent y trouver un intérêt au niveau
des prestations au niveau de la
fiscalité
les élus doivent donc on a une année qui
est comme assez tendue pour mettre tout
cela nous sommes dans cette année enfin
quand je dis tendu c'est à dire vrai
travail
et les bienfaits de la fusion se feront
sentir
je dirais à partir de l'année prochaine
alors les prochaines ya des élections
on verra ce qui se passera mais ce sera
la première élection de la commune
nouvelle pour saint germain ou pour le
chez nero concours elles sont été les
changements les plus notables pour les
administrés du jour au lendemain est ce
que des choses ont changé
parler de la fiscalité est ce que
certains habitants se sont réveillés
avec des impôts plus élevés par exemple
quand on remplit par exemple une
enveloppe pour adresser à monsieur le
maire on met le chesnay rocancourt
c'était la première chose déjà qu'il
fallait changer et donc qu'est ce qui a
changé pour au concours ils ont vu un
petit peu plus de police me sied pas un
peu plus de jardiniers les chesnaysiens
ben on leur a fait découvrir ou hétéro
concours les pistes cyclabes et où on
découvre les autres c'est-à-dire que
quand vous vous mariez vous pensez
connaître effectivement votre conjoint
et puis quand vous êtes sous le même
toit vous dis tiens j'avais pas pensé
qu'ils avaient ça j'avais pas pensé qu
avait ça que du bon bien sûr et pas de
mauvais même chose c'est encore le
moment de la découverte qu'est ce qui
change aujourd'hui notablement pour les
administrés ça qu'on a on a pris entre
élus à se découvrir pendant la
préparation pendant les études mais
c'est vrai que maintenant on apprend à
travailler ensemble et comme dit
philippe c'est vrai que nous on est très
proches au niveau sociologie des
habitants de saint germain il faut qu'
on est très proches sur l'international
mais saint germanois connaissez pas bien
pour que les foules que je connais c'est
un peu mieux saint-germain parce que
c'est la ville centre et qui venait
régulièrement sur les marchés sur les
enfants sont sur les collèges et les
lycées de saint germain mais voilà on
apprend à se prendre un coup moi je
dirais que l'année en cours elle est
d'une année de travail très dense dire
que après l'arrêté du préfet le vrai
travail commence et c'est un travail d'
accord de mise en place de
l'administration la commune nouvelle est
en moi je le ferai un petit part à ce
petit paragraphe sur les appels et les
territoriaux c'est très important des
associés au changement
parce que pour des commandes et des
fonctionnaires territoriaux de la
commune de fourqueux peu près 80 un
fonctionnaire par rapport à son gamin
720 e cd qu'on appelle des couteaux
suisses 1 c'est-à-dire dans une commune
de 3500 il fait tout le territorial est
capable de faire un jour les espaces
verts et un autre jour la voir et nous à
saint germain on avait une
administration beaucoup plus en silo
centralisée et c'est vrai que ça dans la
confusion de communes c'est quelque
chose qui peut faire peur et qui
compliquée à mettre en oeuvre un ami
plus de six mois à le faire donc vous
voyez c'est quand même un peu long mais
en même temps il faut pas que ces pelles
de transition
trop longtemps parce que on voit bien
aussi comme c'est philippe quand on a
deux adjoints scolaire il faut savoir
qu'il est le seul qui va prendre la main
l'autre il va dire mais je n'ai rien à
faire donc c'est vrai que quand on vit
avec 70 élus pour cinq à main il faut
que l'ensemble c'est quand même à un
moment où on peut pas faire ça pendant
deux trois ans donc je dirais en
consigne il faut que cette période de
transition entre le moment où il va y
avoir la création de la commune et le
prochain mandat
il faut pas trop de temps parce que
cette période de mélange je ne sais pas
si on est encore à 70 soit 45
ça fait qu'il ya des questions qui se
posent des fois certains élus se bat
comme dans l'intercommunalité se sentent
un petit peu des saisies un peu de
démotivation alors qu'il ya beaucoup de
travail à faire et je pense qu'en effet
ce temps de travail il est très dense
il faut pas perdre des élus au cours de
route parce qu'on a besoin d'eux pendant
toute la préparation la commune nouvelle
et je pense qu'on est fait comme dit
philippe ces danses très dense mais on
apprend à travailler ensemble et je
trouve que c'est vraiment très
intéressant parce que à saint germain on
a une façon de travailler qui est pas la
même que pour qu il faut trouver le
moyen que tout le monde travaille
ensemble d'une façon qui est bonne pour
la commune bonne pour les administrés
parce que c'est ça aussi qu'il faut voir
c'est que la commune nouvelle n'est pas
fait pour les élus avaient fait pour les
administrés c'est vraiment lui sachs
premier alors quelque chose oui mais qui
parle beaucoup et finalement je pensais
que je parlais plus mais ne te fais pas
presque non je crois que c'est important
si c'est ce qu'entend en tant que
médecin c'est l'adn c'est à dire que
quand vous habitez pour que rocancourt
haute
on n'a pas envie de voir disparaître ses
origines même si on a une société où les
origines ne semble-t-il n'aurait plus
d'importance moi je pense qu'elle en a
quand même et que l'adn de chaque ville
doit être conservée c'est pour ça que la
loi prévoit de pouvoir conserver ce
qu'on appelle les communes déléguées
si je prends les deux communes de
chaîner rocancourt les deux pouvaient
avoir une communes déléguées sept
communes déléguées permet d'avoir le
maire délégué qui a la compétence de
l'état civil serre que quand vous
habitez dans le quartier de rocquencourt
puisque c'est maintenant un quartier
vous ne pouvez pas vous marier à la
mairie du chanet vous ne pouvez vous
marier qu'à la mairie de concours et
pareil pour le chesnay savez devront
dire que on peut garder une commune
délégué rocancourt garder sa commune
délégué nous on n'en voyait pas
l'intérêt
donc il y a la possibilité de pouvoir
assumer pour les habitants
cette transition puisqu'il ya plus de
chez nous il n'y a plus de recours toi
il ya plus que des chaînes est courtoise
et des chaînes de courtois parce qu'il
faut trouver aussi le nom qui permet
donc voilà tout ça ça permet vous savez
c'est comme quand vous vous mariez des
personnes
la femme signe mon nom de jeune fille ou
mon nom de femme mariée ce que vous
voulez eh ben ce que vous voulez et
après ça devient naturel pour la suite
avec ces élections municipales qui
approche pour mars et ce qui est encore
des changements à prévoir une réduction
du nombre d'élus peut-être des
ajustements êtes vous êtes des gens
croient pas électorale ça va mais très
introduit dans le compte de campagne ça
non non en tout cas est ce qu'il y aura
des ce qu'est ce qui est prévu ne serait
ce que par le cadre légal est ce que
maintenant qu'ils auraient une nouvelle
élection pour la première fois vos
électeurs nous sommes 51 prochaines
élections sera beaucoup moins
donc ça rsa réduit et notre engagement
c'est que en mars prochain ont pu se
présenter aux électeurs les engagements
que nous avons fait dans un budget que
nous avons voté ensemble
au mois d'avril le budget c'est la
traduction d'une volonté politique la
volonté politique
ça se juge sur la réalité des choses en
mars nous serons jugés sur la réalité
nos engagements en partir sur la
campagne électorale non plus mais
aujourd'hui on peut on peut a aussi
annoncé pour les électeurs qui aura
quelques changements en moins de moins
d'élus notamment peut-être pas sensé la
loi qu'il impose à nous sur saint
germain on passe de soixante dix on
passera à 45
c'est à dire la strate au dessus et en
2026 on passera à 43 donc voyez il ya
une réduction du nombre d'élus dans le
temps mais pour cent sauf si tu fusionne
avec d'autres communes oui encore mais
si j'ai ce qu'on appelle des surfusion
dans deux androïdes et des communes
nouvelles avec six sept ou huit neuf
communes
là ils ont des conseils municipaux qui
sont très très nombreux et par contre la
loi est très dur et presque des intercos
exactement c'est près d'un terreau
connaissent 200 élus c'est des outils
complémentaires aux interclubs où les
fumeurs à part les mecs qu'est ce qui
change par rapport à l'interco et est-ce
que ça permet de peser plus aussi au
sein d'une attaque aux fusils
l'intercours n'est plus tôt obligé dans
la fusion on se permet ensemble de
décider au début j'avoue franchement je
n'étais pas un fan de la commune
nouvelle parce que je me disais que
l'interco c'était la solution pour les
communes du fait de on va dire la
subsidiarité d'exercer au mieux au plus
près la compétence au moindre coût aux
l'interco elle était dévoyé par les
douanes otremba pam qui fait qu'en fait
l'intercajou pauvre son rôle est donc
pour moi la commune nouvelle
qu'initialement n'était pas forcément un
combat
apportez est devenu en effet un combat à
porter parce que ça permet sur un
territoire d'exercer librement des
compétences et de maintenir un service
public que malheureusement l'intercours
dans cette taille xxl ne permet pas
d'assumer de façon pleinement et
s'éloigne plus de la deûle administrés
que la commune et non je pense que c'est
une chance justement eu la commune
nouvelle de pouvoir exercer au mieux de
la proximité pour nos citoyens et comme
dit philippe à juste titre on va garder
nous sur four que la commune délégué de
fourqueux on a gardé une mairie annexe
l'état civil se fait sur fourqueux on a
même amené la biométrie sur faut que
qu'ils n'avaient pas avant donc ils
n'ont pu aller à saint germain donc on
maintient la proximité et ça c'est
important parce que des administrés
comme disait on veut le garder leur adn
ils veulent garder aussi leur service
public donc la loi nous oblige à un
certain nombre de choses mais c'est les
élus qui vont écrire l'avenir et c'est
comme tu dis le budget qui va être la
transcription des engagements la commune
nouvelle dans le respect des chartes
on a écrit mais c'est une nouvelle
majorité une nouvelle équipe qui va la
porter on verra en 2020 alors des
différents débats on va s'arrêter là
pour parler justement d'accompagner les
temps juste le dernier point oui le
conseil départemental des yvelines a
pris des délibérations pour encourager
les villes a fusionné avec des aides
importantes
d'où la chanson marions-les marions les
il faut se marier
voilà et à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à cette table ronde c'était la
dernière concernant tv et 78 pour cette
université des mairies 2019 merci aux
organisateurs de nous avoir reçus on se
retrouvera bien sûr l'année prochaine
sur ce stand pour poursuivre les
discussions avec les élus
et puis toutes nos émissions sont à voir
en replay bien évidemment dès à présent
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis et
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]